بعد وقوع الزلزال هنا في محافظه جيبو
غربيه جزيره جاوه الاندونيسيه ازدحمت
مستشفيات المحافظه وحتى في مناطق محيطه
بماءات الجرحى والمصابين هؤلاء الجرحى
والمصابون بحاجه الى فرق اضافيه من
الاطباء من اخصائي العظام والجراحه العامه
لاجراء عمليات الجراحيه لهم خلال ايام
المقبله العدد يزيد كلما تم فتح الطرق
المسدوده بفعل انهيارات الارضيه في الجبال
المحيطه التي عزلت بعض القرى عن مركز
المحافظه كلما وصلت سياره الاسعاف الى تلك
القرى جلبت المزيد من الجرحى والمصابين
اضافه الى عدد لم تنتهي حسبته من القتله
هذه المنطقه منطقه شينجور تعرضت لكثير من
الزلازل خلال قرن المضى ابتداء من عام
1910 وكذلك في عام 1912 وفي عام 68 وكذلك
في عام
2000 في عام 2000 تعرضت هذه المنطقه
لزلزال خلف نحو الفي منزل مهدم والعديد من
الضحايا واليوم نتحدث عن تقريبا عدد مقارب
نتحدث عن ما بين 1000 1800 الى 2000 منزل
متهدم وهذا يفسر وجود نحو 5000 متضرر
بحاجه الى اعاده اعماره منازلهم هذا
الزلزال هو الاقوى الذي تتعرض له
اندونيسيا خلال عامين تقريبا زلزال الاقوى
الاخير كان في يناير من العام الماضي
تحديدا في اقليم سلوسي الغربيه
صهيب جاسم الجزيره محافظه شانجور في اقليم
الغربيه